I like using object to make sound that
the intention of the maker of that
object was not that it be used as a
musical instrument
um and I like them for their sound and
also for the incongruity of the visual
of seeing them
so um using big sheets of Plexiglas to
make make a sound or using this giant
water bottle or
um a slinky or a or a or some power
tools or you know I have one piece that
I made with a group that I used to
collaborate with where we had hair
clippers on stage this is you know we
were using hair clippers
so um so I just sort of enjoy
taking objects and language out of its
original intended context and moving it
into another context because it just
makes it it changes it for people makes
them think differently about it when
it's in a different context and
um yeah